Thank you Thank You Sean thank you
thank you
thank you very much
thank you thank you for your kind
welcome and thank you sean for your kind
introduction President Jerry Cohen and
mrs. maureen Cohen and thank you
everyone who is coming this morning I
appreciate the hospitality of the
Allegheny conference Pittsburgh Tex
council and the students and faculty of
Carnegie Mellon University we have a
strong showing this morning from the
Carnegie Mellon naval ROTC unit as well
and I'm happy to be with all of you this
university as a fine reputation for its
programs in business finance and other
disciplines in the field of economics
six Nobel Peace Nobel Prize winners and
it's always worth recalling that
economics is not a subject that can be
wrenched apart from all the rest of life
or from the values that give life
direction when we debate economic policy
we're talking about after all the
deepest hopes that carry each of us
along in the work we do and about all
the things we wish for ourselves and for
each other and these can't simply be
measured by simply running the numbers
in our free society it's left to each
one of us to make our own way in the
world and our jobs businesses savings
pensions farms and homes are the work of
years take these away and you're
diminishing a lot more than the GDP or
the final tally on the big board on Wall
Street take these away and a million
dreams are undone the gains of hard work
and sacrifice are lost and something can
be lost that is very crucial in our
economy and very slow to return
confidence confidence every so often in
our nation's capital weary learned this
lesson when the excesses of traders and
speculators and the poor planning of
politicians catches up with them and the
troubles spread
are beyond wall street in washington
this has happened in recent months at
great cost to workers small businesses
families and homeowners across our
nation and calling these serious
problems a correction in the market or a
cycle of the economy doesn't make their
situation any better their jobs and
homes any safer or their lives any
easier as you all know economic policy
is not just some academic exercise and
we in Washington are not just passive
spectators we have a responsibility to
act and if I'm elected president I
intend to act quickly and decisively we
need reforms that promote growth and
opportunity we need rules that are sure
fairness and punish wrongdoing in the
market we need tax policies that respect
the wage earners and job creators who
make this economy run and help them to
succeed in what you all know is a global
economy in all of this it will not be
enough simply to dust off the economic
policies of 48 or 28 years ago we have
our own work to do we have our own
challenges to me millions of working men
and women in Pennsylvania Ohio Michigan
and beyond can tell you how urgent is
the work before us one man put it to
this way to a reporter not long ago and
reply to a question about the job he
have just lost he said I told my wife
but I'll always keep a roof over her
head now I worry about keeping that
promise in the monthly reports of our
labor department nearly 250,000
Americans like this man were let go
recently and suddenly from jobs that
they thought were safe a woman in the
town of trainer in delaware county also
captured the feeling of many
she described what it's like to work and
save for years and at the age of 47
still struggle for the basics of life
the family has had medical problems and
as she puts it trust me no one wants to
be in our shoes and lots of people are
just a sick husband away from where we
are for citizens like these doing their
best to keep promises and meet
obligations there's no comfort in
knowing their problems are common and
their worries are shared meanwhile the
people we expect to be most sober and
level heading their economic decisions
bankers and other home lenders forgot
some of the basic standards of their own
profession hard-working homeowners are
learning for the first time about the
endlessly complicated borrowing bundling
and betting it's been going on in our
capital markets Americans worry about a
system they worry about a system that
allows for me and bad loans to affect 51
million good ones they wonder how assets
can so quickly become liabilities and
why the high-risk games of a few were
permitted to inflict such Grievous harms
on our entire financial system my
friends a little straight talk Americans
are also right to be offended when the
extravagant salaries and severance deals
of CEOs in some cases the very same CEOs
who helped bring on these market
troubles bear no relation no relation to
the success of the company or the wishes
of the stockholders something seriously
wrong when the American people are left
to bear the consequences of reckless
corporate conduct while mr. Kane of bear
stearns mr. mozilo of countrywide and
others are packed off with another 40 or
50 million for the road
I leave it for others to speculate on
the technical definition of the
recession it's all a little beside the
point if it's your plant that's closing
and your job that's gone and when you
are facing foreclosure or back in debt
after years of hard effort are hardly
able to buy food gas or heating for your
home in the end the truest measure of
prosperity in America is the success and
financial security of those who earn
wages and meet payrolls in this country
many are waiting for their first homes
the first big break the first shot at
financial security and helping them will
be my first priority in setting the
economic policies of this nation in so
many ways even now the workers and
entrepreneurs of America are taken for
granted by their government while the
lobbyists and special pleaders are
seldom turned away by the tens of
billions of dollars our tax money is
routinely squandered by the Congress on
less than useless pork barrel projects
having nothing to do with the purposes
of government and everything to do with
the preservation of power
in the same way many in Congress think
Americans are under taxed they speak as
if letting you keep your own earnings or
an act of charity and now they've
decided you've had enough by allowing
many of the current low tax rates to
expire they would impose overnight the
largest single tax increase since the
Second World War among supporters of a
tax increase our senators Obama and
Clinton both promised big change and a
trillion dollars in new taxes over the
next decade would certainly fit that
description of course they'd like you to
think that only the very wealthy will
pay more in taxes but the reality is
quite different under my opponents
various tax plans Americans of every
background would see their taxes rise
seniors parents small business owners
and just about everyone who has even a
modest investment in the market all
these tax increases are under the fine
print of the slogan hope they're going
to raise your taxes by thousands of
dollars a year and they have the
audacity audacity to hope you don't mind
they an hour others argue that the tax
increase is necessary in part to finance
Social Security and Medicare
unfortunately this claim only serves to
remind us of Congress's consistent
failure to repair both of these programs
even under the best of circumstances for
years for years Congress has been buying
time and leaving the great challenge of
entitlement reform for others to deal
with and now the two contenders in the
other party have even proposed enormous
new federal commitments before the old
commitments have been kept trusting that
others somewhere down the road we'll
handle the financing and make all the
numbers come out right but there will
come a day my friend
yo come a day when the road dead-ends
and the old excuses seem even more
hollow and it won't be the politicians
who bear the consequences it'll be
American workers and their children who
are left with worthless promises and
multitrillion-dollar debts we cannot we
cannot let that happen and you have my
pledge as president I will work with
every member of Congress Republican
Democrat and independent who shares my
commitment to reforming and protecting
Medicare and Social Security you have my
commitment
in so many ways we need to make a clean
break from the worst excesses of both
political parties for Republicans it
starts with reclaiming our good name our
good name is the party of spending
restraint somewhere along the way too
many Republicans in Congress became
indistinguishable from the big-spending
Democrats they used to oppose the only
power of government that could stop them
was the power of veto the power of veto
and it was rarely used if that authority
is entrusted to me I'll use the veto is
needed and as our founding fathers
intended I will veto every bill with
earmarks until the Congress stops
sending bills with earmarks on them I
will keep detailing I will make some
payments and you will know their names
I will seek a constitutionally valid
line-item veto d and the practice once
and for all I will lead across-the-board
reforms in the federal tax code removing
myriad corporate tax loopholes that are
costly unfair and inconsistent with a
free market economy as president I will
also order a prompt and thorough review
of the budgets of every federal program
department and agency while that top to
bottom review is underway we will
institute a one-year pause in
discretionary spending increases with a
necessary exemption of military
expending and veterans benefits
discretionary spending is a term people
throw around a lot in Washington while
actual discretion is seldom exercise
instead every program comes with a
built-in assumption that it should go on
forever and its budget increase forever
my administration will change that way
of thinking I'll hold the agencies of
the federal government for the money
they spend accountable I'll make sure
the public helps me and I'll provide
federal agencies with the best executive
leadership that can be found in America
we're going to make every aspect of
government purchases and performance
transparent information on every step of
contracts and grants will be posted on
the Internet in plain and simple English
we're going to post an agency's
performance evaluation as well we're
going to demand accountability we will
make sure that federal spending serves
the common interests the failed programs
are not rewarded and that discretionary
spending is going where it belongs to
essential priorities like job training
the security of our citizens and the
care of our veterans my administration
there will be no more subsidies for
special pleaders no more corporate
welfare no more throwing around busy
billions of dollars of the people's
money on
projects while the people themselves the
people themselves are struggling to
afford their homes groceries and gas
we're going to get our priorities
straight in Washington a clean break
from years of squandered wealth and
wasted chances I have a clear record my
friends I have a clear record of not
asking for a single earmark from my
state
and my States doing pretty well for
their part senators Obama and Clinton of
championed a long list championed a long
list of pork barrel projects for their
states like the all-important Woodstock
Museum all-important Woodstock museum
that Senator Clinton expected Americans
to pay for at the cost of a million
dollars that kind of careless spending
of tax dollars has not changed my
friends it's business as usual in
Washington and it's all part the same
wasteful and corrupting system that we
need to end the goal of reform however
is not merely to check waste and keep a
tidy budget process although these are
important enough in themselves the great
goal is to get the American economy
running at full strength again creating
the opportunities Americans expect and
the jobs Americans need and one very
direct way to achieve that is by taking
the savings from earmark program review
and other budget reforms which is on the
order of a hundred billion dollars
annually and use those savings to lower
the business income tax for every
employer that pays it so i will send a
congress a proposal it's okay
so I will send to Congress a proposal to
cut the taxes these employers pay from a
rate of thirty five to twenty five
percent as it is we have the second
highest tax on business in the
industrialized world high tax rates
driving businesses and jobs overseas and
of course our foreign competitors
wouldn't mind if we kept it that way but
if I'm elected president we're going to
get rid of that drag on growth and job
creation and help American workers
compete with any company in the world I
will also send to the Congress a
middle-class tax cut a complete phase
out of the alternative minimum tax to
save more than 25 million middle-class
families more than two thousand dollars
every single year
our tax laws and those who enforce them
should treat all citizens with respect
whether they are married or single but
mothers and fathers bear special
responsibilities and the tax code should
recognize this inflation has eroded the
value of the exemption for dependents
I'll send to Congress a reform to
increase the exemption with the goal of
doubling it from 3500 dollars to seven
thousand dollars for every dependent in
every family in America the tax laws of
America should also promote and reward
innovation because obviously innovation
creates jobs tax laws shouldn't smother
the ingenuity of our people with
needless regulations and disincentives
so I'll propose and sign into law a
reform agenda to permit the first year
expensive new of expensive new equipment
and technology to ban internet taxes
permanently to ban cell phone taxes
this one might appeal to this audience
to ban new cell phone taxes and and to
make the tax credit for research and
development permanent so that we never
lose our competitive edge it's not
enough however to make these little
fixes here and there in the tax code
what we need what we have a compelling
requirement for is a simpler flatter and
a fairer tax code as
as president I will propose an
alternative tax system an alternative
tax system when this reform is enacted
all who wish to be under the current
system could still do so and everyone
else could choose a vastly less
complicated system with two tax rates
and a generous standard deduction period
period Americans don't resent paying
their rightful share of taxes what they
do resent is being subjected to
thousands of pages of needless and often
irrational rules and demands from the
IRS
we know from experience that no serious
reform of the current tax code will come
out of Congress that's another little
Straight Talk so it's now it's time to
turn the decision over the people we're
going to create a new and simpler tax
system and give the American people a
choice better tax policy is just one
part of a pro-growth agenda that
includes smarter regulation a leaner
more focused government and among the
many benefits to America these reforms
will help to create jobs improve the
investment climate attract global
investors and strengthen the dollar
strengthened the daughter also Americans
worry about stagnant wages which are
caused in part by the rising cost of
health care each year employers pay more
and more for insurance leaving less and
less to pay their employees as president
I will propose and relentlessly advocate
changes that will bring down health care
costs make health care more affordable
and accessible and help individuals and
families by their health insurance with
generous tax credits and enable you to
keep your insurance when you change jobs
I can't tell you the number of people at
worry but when they change jobs and
their ability to keep their health
insurance many Retired Americans face
the terrible reality of deciding whether
to buy food pay rent or buy their
prescriptions and their government
should help them but when we added the
prescription drug benefit to Medicare a
new and incredibly costly entitlement we
included many people who are more than
capable of purchasing their own medicine
without assistance from taxpayers who
struggle to purchase their own people
like Bill Gates Warren Buffett don't
need their prescriptions in underwritten
by taxpayers those who can afford to buy
their own prescription drugs should be
expected to do so this will form a loan
this reform alone will save billions of
dollars that could be returned to
taxpayers are put to
there's never been a problem Americans
couldn't solve we're the world's leaders
leaders don't fear change pine for the
past and dread the future we make the
future better than the past we make the
future that's why I object that's why I
object when senators Obama and Clinton
and others preach the false virtues of
economic isolationism senator Obama
recently suggested that Americans are
protectionists because they're bitter
about being left behind in the global
economy well maybe that's his excuse for
embracing the false premises and
promises of protectionism opening new
markets for American goods and services
is indispensable to our future
prosperity we can compete with anyone we
can compete with anyone senators Obama
and Clinton think we should hide behind
walls bury our heads and industries in
the sand and hope we have enough left to
live on while the world passes us by but
that's not good policy and it's not good
leadership and the shortsightedness of
these policies can be seen today in
Congress's refusal to vote on the
Colombian free trade agreement when new
trading partners can sell in our market
and Americans can companies can sell and
there's the gains are great and they're
lasting the strength of the American
economy offers a better life to every
society we trade with and the good comes
back to us in many ways in better jobs
higher prices higher wages and lower
prices and lower prices my friends
free trade free trade can also give once
troubled and impoverished nations to
stake in the world economy and in their
relations with America in the case of
Colombia a friend a crucial democratic
ally its stability and economic vitality
are more critical now as others in the
region seek to turn Latin America away
from democracy and away from our country
trade serves all of these national
interests and the interests of the
American economy as well and I call on
the Congress once again to put this
vital agreement to an up-or-down vote I
know that open markets don't
automatically translate into a higher
quality of life for every single
American change is hard change is hard
while most of us gain some industries
companies and workers are left to
struggle with very very difficult
choices and government should help
workers they should help workers get the
education and training they need for the
new jobs that will be created by new
businesses in this new century right now
we have more than a half a dozen
programs that are supposed to help
displaced workers and for those who are
not working at all we have an
unemployment insurance program straight
out of the 1950s it was dessert it was
designed to assist workers through a few
tough months during an economic downturn
until our old jobs came back that
program has no relevance to the world we
live in today if I'm elected president I
work with Congress in the states to make
job training and unemployment insurance
what it should be a swift plan from a
job that's not coming back to a job that
won't go away
we'll build a new system using the
unemployment insurance tactus taxes to
build for each worker a buffer account
against a sudden loss of income so that
in times of need they're not just told
to fill out forms and take a number and
we'll draw on the great strengths of
America's Community College's their
community colleges applying the funds
from federal trading accounts to give
displaced workers of every age a fresh
start with new skills and new
opportunities these reforms must wait on
the next election but to help our
workers on our economy we must also act
in the here and now now we must start we
must start with the subprime mortgage
crisis with the hundreds of thousands of
citizens who played by the rules yet now
fear losing their houses under the home
plan I have proposed our government will
offer these Americans direct and
immediate help that can make all the
difference if you can't make your
payments and you're in danger of
foreclosure you'll be able to go to any
post office and pick up a form for a new
home loan in place of your flawed
mortgage loan you'll be eligible for a
new 30 year fixed rate loan backed by
the United States government citizens
will keep their homes lenders will cut
their losses and everyone will move on
following the sounder practices that
should have been observed in the first
place
it's as important as well to remember
that the foolish risk-taking lenders
investment banks and others that led to
these troubles don't reflect our free
market as it should be working in a free
market there must be transparency
accountability and personal and
corporate responsibility to state the
obvious housing crisis came about
because these standards collapsed and as
president I intend to restore them the
great problems in the housing market
have been viral spreading out to affect
the credit and buying power of Americans
even as the price of oil and gas is
rising as never before there are larger
problems underlying the price of oil all
of which i'll address in my energy plan
but in the short term there are crucial
measures we can take i propose that the
federal government suspend all taxes on
gasoline now paid by the american people
from Memorial Day to Labor Day of this
year
the effect will be an immediate economic
stimulus taking a few dollars off the
price of a tank of gas every time a
family a farmer or trucker stops to fill
up over the same period our government
should suspend the purchase of oil for
the Strategic Petroleum Reserve which is
also contributed to the rising price of
oil this measure combined with the
summer long gas tax holiday will bring a
timely reduction in the price of
gasoline and because the cost of gas
affects the price of food packaging and
just about everything else these
immediate steps will help to spread
relief across the American economy by
summer's end moreover millions of
college students will be counting on
their student loans to come through and
we need to make sure that happens those
loans must come through these
these young Americans including perhaps
some of you at CMU are among the many
citizens whose ability to obtain a loan
might be seriously hurt by far away
problems not of their own making so
today i propose that the Department of
Education work with the governor's to
make sure that each state's guarantee
agency has the means and manpower to
meet its obligation as a lender of last
resort for student loans in the years
ahead these young Americans will be
needed to sustain America's primacy in
the global marketplace and they should
not be denied an education because of
the recklessness of others has made
credit too hard to obtain these these
are just some of the reforms I intend to
fight for and differences I'll debate
with whoever my Democratic opponent is
in the weeks and months ahead I'll
detail my plans to reform health care in
America to make our schools more
accountable to parents and taxpayers to
keep America's edge and technology to
use the power of free markets to grow
our economy to escape our dependence on
foreign oil the guard against climate
change and be better stewards of this
earth that we inhabit all of these
challenges
all of these challenges and more will
face the next president and I will not
leave them for some unluckier generation
of leaders to deal with we're going to
restore the confidence of the American
people in the future of this blessed and
great country
I do not seek the presidency on the
presumption that I am blessed with such
personal greatness that history has
anointed me to save my country in its
hour of need I seek the presidency with
the humility of a man who cannot forget
that my country saved me I'm running to
serve America and a champion the ideas i
believe will help us do what every
American generation has done to make in
our time and from our challenges a safer
stronger more prosperous country and a
better world as I have always done I
will make my case to every American who
will listen I will not confine myself to
the comfort of speaking only to those
who agree with me I'll make my case to
all the people I will listen to those
who disagree I will try to persuade them
I will debate and I will learn from them
but i will fight every moment of every
day for what I believe is right for this
country and I will not yield thank you